♪
BUT HE WOULD ALSO BE
VIOLATING THE RULES OF THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED
STATES.
TUCK THE RELEASE OF THIS
MEMO IS REALLY REMINISCENT
OF THE DARKEST DAYS OF THE
MCCARTHY ERA.
>> THERE IS ZERO PROOF OR
EVEN EVIDENCE THAT THERE IS
POLITICAL BIAS IN THE FBI IF
YOU SAY IT LONG ENOUGH AND
IT.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT
PATRIOTIC IF YOU WANT YOUR
QUESTIONS ANSWERED.
DEMOCRATS ARE LASHING OUT.
SOMETHING PROFOUND IS
HAPPENING HERE.
THEY ARE VERY UPSET BY THE
RELEASE OF THE FBI MEMO.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADERBOARD
FRIEND PUTIN A BOUQUET.
MANY HAVE SAID SIMILAR
JOINS US TONIGHT.
MANY DEMOCRATS INCLUDING
LEADERS PELOSI AND SCHIFF
TWO SAID THE RELEASE WOULD
JEOPARDIZE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE A LIE
PROVABLABLY THERE WAS
NOTHING IN THIS CLASSIFIED
NO.
OBVIOUS REASON IT WAS
CLASSIFIED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
WHY WOULD THEY TELL US THAT
WHEN THEY KNEW IT WASN'T
YOU SHOULD BE CONCERNED
YOU SHOULD READ THE MEMO.
>> Tucker: I DID.
>> JUST BECAUSE YOU KNEW THE
SOURCES BEFOREHAND BECAUSE
THEY WERE REPORTED ON
DOESN'T MEAN WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THEM IN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: PLEASE BE PRECISE
ABOUT HOW IT JEOPARDIZES OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY BECAUSE A
LOT OF US ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT DOING THAT I WOULD
NEVER WANT TO PLAY ANY ROLE
IN DOING THAT.  THAT'S WHY
IT'S SUCH A SERIOUS CHARGE.
>> YOU ARE PLAYING A ROLE IN
DOING THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: TELL ME HOW.
>> BECAUSE, WE DON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE SOURCES IN
ONGOING INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Tucker: WHAT SOURCE ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT AND HOW
DOES THAT IMPERIL OUR
COUNTRY.
>> WELL, THE MEMO GOES INTO
PAPSD AND PAGE AND OTHERS
THAT YOU ONLY KNEW ABOUT
BECAUSE THEY WERE REPORTED
ON NOT BECAUSE.
>> Tucker: I KNEW BECAUSE
PAPADOPOULOS WAS INDICTED
AND THE MEMO CAME OUT TODAY.
EXPLAIN HOW YOU JUST ACCUSED
ME OF ENDANGERING AMERICAN
NATIONAL SECURITY I THINK
IT'S FAIR FOR YOU TO BE VERY
PRECISE IN EXPLAINING HOW
>> Tucker: NO, NOT THE
LARGER DANGER.
ON THAT.
YOU JUST.
>> I ALREADY WENT ON THAT.
>> Tucker: YOU GOT TWO
EXPLAIN IT I THINK IT'S FAIR
TO EXPLAIN WHAT YOU MEANT
WHEN YOU SAID I WAS -- HOW
DOES THAT JEOPARDIZE OUR
COUNTRY'S SECURITY?
>> BECAUSE WE DON'T REVEAL
THE SOURCES IN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
TUCKER, RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: SO NOW THAT THIS
HAS BEEN REVEALED HOW IS
THIS IN DANGER.
>> IN EVERY POLICE STATION
IN AMERICA THE POLICE ARE
INTERVIEW AGO SUSPECT.
YOU ARE SUGGESTING THAT WE
THE QUESTION.
>> Tucker: WHO IS THE
SUSPECT?
WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
>> IN THIS COUNTRY.
INVESTIGATION.
THE WHITE HOUSE ARE SUBJECT
OF THE RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: I'M TALKING ABOUT
THIS MUCH TALKED ABOUT MEMO
TODAY.
I LISTENED TO PEOPLE TELL ME
NOW EXPLICITLY TELL ME I'M
HURTING THIS COUNTRY BY
READING IT?
>> ALSO HURTING THE COUNTRY
BY NOT ACKNOWLEDGING THE
RULE OF LAW RUN OVER.
THEY ARE USING THE POLICE.
ATTACKING THE POLICE BECAUSE
>> Tucker: ONE SERIOUS CRIME
AT A TIME.
>> I STILL LIKE YOU TUCKER
BUT I THINK YOU ARE WRONG ON
THIS ONE.
>> Tucker: NOT ANSWERING
THIS QUESTION.
>> I ANSWERED A BUNCH OF
QUESTIONS.
YOU DON'T LIKE THE ANSWER.
THAT'S OUT PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: WE KNOW FROM THIS
THAT CARTER PAGE FOUR TIMES
WAS DESCRIBED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, BY
THE FBI, AS AN AGENT OF A
FOREIGN POWER, RUSSIA.
FOUR TIMES.
SO THE QUESTION.
>> AND IN 201 AS WELL.
>> Tucker: HE WAS NOT
COMMITTEE.
YOU SHOULD READ THE
TESTIMONY TO OUR COMMITTEE.
>> Tucker: SOMETHING THAT
HASN'T BEEN REVEALED BEFORE
TODAY.
>> SOMETHING YOU SHOULD HAVE
READ HIS TESTIMONY TO OUR
COMMITTEE HE ACKNOWLEDGED HE
WAS PERSON A IN THE
INDICTMENT IN 2014 WHERE HE
WAS SUSPECTED OF BEING A
RUSSIAN FOREIGN AGENT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK WAS
ACCUSED OF IT?
>> HE WAS SUSPECTED IT.
ACCUSED HIM OF THAT, BEFORE
IS A FOREIGN AGENT?
SIMPLE QUESTION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> HE WAS UNDER SUSPICION.
IT'S AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION THAT'S NOT
CLOSED.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM, TUCKER.
>> IT'S STILL OPEN.
YOU WANT US TO COMMENT ON IT
IT'S OPEN.
IT'S STILL AN OPEN
INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE ENTITLED
IF YOU ARE GOING TO IMPUGN
THE MAN'S CHARACTER AS YOU
HAVE RELENTLESSLY HAVE.
ACCUSING HIM COMMITTING
TREASON.
ASK YOU HONEST QUESTION
STRAIGHTFORWARD NO INNUENDO,
DO YOU THINK IS HE BETRAYING
HIS COUNTRY?
>> I THINK YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWING THE FBI TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION WITH WHAT YOU
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU GOT TO
BE KIDDING.
ALL I WANT IS FOR MY
QUESTIONS TO BE ANSWERED.
I SIT HERE AN OPEN, WILLING,
MEMO, INCLUDING THE
DOCUMENTS THAT SUPPORTED
THIS MEMO, INCLUDING THE
TESTIMONY.
>> SO YOU SUPPORT OUR MEMO
COMING OUT?
I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE I DO.
>> YOU SUPPORT OUR MEMO
COMING OUT?
>> Tucker: ABSOLUTELY I DO.
I SUPPORT ALL INFORMATION
THAT GETS TO THE TRUTH.
>> INVITE ME BACK.
I WILL BE IN WASHINGTON.
ALLEGATIONS ABOUT OTHER
AMERICANS THAT YOU CANNOT
SUPPORT AS WHEN YOU SAID I
WAS HARMING OUR COUNTRY'S
NATIONAL SECURITY AND WHEN
YOU SUGGESTED CARTER PAGE
WAS BETRAYING THIS NATION.
>> YOU ARE PEDDLING A
NARRATIVE THAT UNDERMINES
QUESTION.
YOU JUST SAID ON MY AIR, ON
MY SHOW YOU ARE IMPERILING
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
I SAID OH, REALLY
CONGRESSMAN, HOW AM I DOING
THAT?
AM I GOING TO BE ARRESTED
FOR THAT?
I DON'T KNOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING A
MAN COULD BE ARRESTED FOR.
>> YEAH.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT TIMES IN
OUR HISTORY.
EITHER YOU ARE SUPPORTING
THOSE UNDERMINING THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE RULE OF LAW OR YOU ARE
STANDING FIRM IN SAYING THIS
IS WRONG.
TUCKER, I WISH YOU WERE ON
MY SIDE BECAUSE I THINK YOU
KNOW BETTER.
ABOUT.
I ONLY WISH.
>> I THINK YOU DON'T LIKE
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> Tucker: I DEFINITELY
DON'T LIKE WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT BUT MORE
PROFOUNDLY I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT AND WHEN YOU
ACCUSE SOMEONE.
>> READ OUR MEMO WHEN IT IS
RELEASED NEXT WEEK.
>> Tucker: GAME IT OUT FOR
ME.
TELL ME ONE THING THAT I
HAVE SAID THAT YOU THINK
SAFE?
>> YOU CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE IDEA THAT WE SHOULD GIVE
SUSPECTS IN CRIMINAL CASES
THE EVIDENCE AGAINST THEM
BEFORE WE ASK THEM ANY
NOTHING WRONG.
>> Tucker: I DO THINK WE
SHOULD GIVE THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT THAT THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES ME TO
WHEN IS IT THAT I THINK WE
SHOULD GIVE EVIDENCE TO --
I'M NOT EVEN SURE WHAT THAT
MEANS.
BY THE WAY I THINK PEOPLE
CHARGED IN THE CRIMINAL CASE
HAVE A RIGHT TO THE EVIDENCE
AGAINST THEM, DON'T THEY?
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
>> TUCKER, NOT WHEN THEY ARE
SUSPICION.
DO YOU THINK SO IT'S A
PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: WHAT INFORMATION
HAVE I.
>> RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
DO YOU THINK IT'S A PROBLEM
THAT THEY WERE SENT EVIDENCE
IN THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
WHEN THEY'RE SUBJECTS OF THE
INVESTIGATION?
>> Tucker: WHO IS THEY?
>> YOU DON'T SEE A CONFLICT
THERE?
DONALD TRUMP AND DON MCGAHN.
>> Tucker: IN THE CASE OF
TODAY'S MEMO, WHAT
SPECIFICALLY HAVE I ESPOUSED
THAT IMPOWERS THREATS TO OUR
COUNTRY?
>> YOU ARE PEDDLING THE
NARRATIVE THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS PUTTING
OUT.
WHICH ALSO IS THE PUTIN
NARRATIVE BECAUSE THEY ARE
RETWEETING THIS WITH THEIR
RUSSIAN BOSS.
>> Tucker: DO YOU PERCEIVE
YOU SHOULD TAKE A STEP BACK
AND WONDER WHOSE BIDDING ARE
YOU REALLY DOING?
>> Tucker: I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT TO SAY.
I DON'T WANT TO EXPLODE ON
TV SO I WILL END THIS